W-Wah!
I'm sorry!
What did I do?
I'm going!
Oh!
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Superflight!
Ah!!
I hit the wrong button
*intelligently reading the instructions*
I'm not ready! Wait!
I dont even know the controls *sobbing*
Is this-Is this suppose to be a game pad game??
Uh----Uh---Uh----Uh---AHHH! *Markimoo mating call*
My wrist.......okay (quietly)
Hang on a second, everybod-*starts laughing/sobbing*-yyy
Wuh----I'm setting up my controller!
Ah, there we go!
It's inverted! I hate inverted
No! No! *sobbing*
holes and stuff holes!---
*Crashed*  Ah--, i'm very dead. Okay
So this game is, like you're flying a winged-suit
And as a winged-suit flyer, it's some ---Uh, my controller's ready, you guys know that?
Uh oh (x3) *Crashed* oh~~~
That was not a hole i can go through
I trying to identify the holes i can fly through
I dont like inverted!
Oh-----Uh------
Yes, yes yes, I'm a baller, I'm a shot-caller look at me go
Whoa
Alrighty, then where,the, hell, am, I? oh my goosssh
Whoa I blacked out, I don't know why I blacked out, but I blacked out. Eh, up, and down, okay?
Okay alright this game would be bizzar-kurz in VR, but I'm not playing VR
So let's see what we could do right about now, hang on
Oooo Inverted is weird. Oh, my skull. Can I change that?
Please, no
Invert you mean vert. You mean actually vert it.
Ah that is somehow worse okay, maybe it was a bad idea, okay
BAD IDEA
Okay, let's - No
I don't want you to die yet
Okay
All right, let's try this guy. Okay, so now that we got my bearings about me this game is pretty
cool, Eeeuuu, owh
*more markimoo mating calls*
Ohhhh,  I Almost made that if I could just stop screaming, I think I'd actually be fine. Well. That's not gonna happen in a million billion years
Markiplier stop screaming, I might as well die, i might as well die, i might as well Ooohhh
Okay, I think I caught some wind there that didn't work out the wet bond yeah, man
I really don't like how flappy this guy is
Okay all right come through for a second pass I
Gotta come through for the passes that's it up and then down up
Very nice
Okay, ah
Beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful, I'm a beauty(sure mark)
Okay, all right all right
All right ooh a whole I'm gonna stick my head in that hole too far down
Flying into one of these portals to get a new map oh
Okay, all right, are you sure those trees ain't portals boo. I wasn't paying attention. I was not. I'm sorry okay
All right, I got a wonder. Why this person decided to do wingsuit then again
I don't fully understand most people that would do the wingsuit thing considering how many people died from it
I mean I know it's an adrenaline thing, but personally I like the safety of lan-ah
I
Like the safety of layah(anything you say mark). Okay go down
Where's another halt who wants to give me a hole
That's a weird thing to shout at the top of my lungs who wants to give me a hole?!
So I guess my only objective here is to try it desperately
To not kill the cavalcade of people that are tossing themselves out of a mountain
Just so that they can trust that I won't kill them Dead
But it's a it's a futile gesture
Cuz that's all I know how to do literally all I know how to do is kill him dead kill him dead. Oh
Too close too close it's fine. It's fine. Okay, just going real gingerly. Oh, yeah
Oh, that's the good stuff. Okay hang on. I see a hole. This is not at all. That's a portal
Oh, I found the portal the portal. I found the portal all right. I got this Oh
Spicy, okay, starting to get a hang of it
I'm not getting a good hang of it, but I've got a hang of it. I got a hang nail of it... PORTAL
Don't know where I am? This is weird
I was just getting used to the last map and you're gonna throw me into an ASS backward place like that I
I was fine. I panicked. I'm the one who panicked. Oh boy how am I gonna get out of this one Batman?
Oh, I don't know Robin. How about fly yourself into a mountain?
Oh, no another one of my trucks and kamay trees are dead. Oh my fault. I'm Batman
I Wanted to go through that hole uh
alas, that's the tragedy of all our lives isn't it
Don't know don't oh, you were gonna you did and then you didn't because I told you not to are you?
Okay, I'm not gonna make it through that hole, but I can make it through this. There's a portal there. I see you
I'm coming for you. I'm covered for you por-
Where did you go?  think you can hide from me portal the answer is you cannot, Theres two portals?
Okay, I guess we're here now another portal all right
We're chaining them up!
Where am I? I don't know where I am anymore. :(
I'm in a weird
Wimbley world oh geez oh geez oh geezums
Okay, all right
* Markiplier mating call*
My god that was beautiful for a fresh hot second, and then I was dead
I was extremely
i got achievement for close call, right before I died is that blood on the mountain is that my blood on the mountain?
You know I wouldn't be too surprised all my clones that are throwing themselves so willy nilly down this mountain
You know you'd think that one of them would have learned from the bone
Smacking crunches that they're hearing that maybe it's such a good idea. I don't see many holes
Boy, I wish I had a hoollee
* more markiplier noises*
God it's so scary. I just feel like I just feel like I shouldn't do this. You know whoa oh
Right into the gap we go. That's fine gap. Though. Oh, I'm just gonna go straight down. I don't like this map
I'm going for another
I'm dying. Oh god. I don't know why I decided to send me into the vomit zone, but it did
Portal all right, okay?
Nope there's nothing there's nothing there to punch nothing is this all randomly generated. I would very impressive
This is all randomly generated, but alas i-i-i did not, how is that not a hole?
That was such a hole now. It's a holiest hole. I've ever hold and I've hold a lot of holes in my day
Oh come on. Give me a hole ooh. I see a portal that's kind of a hole into another universe
oh
This looks familiar wait. No it's purple hey Now. I can never tell with these purple familiar things
Oh another portal hell yeah, Oh brown-brown and grey
All right any holes
I'm really good looking for holes
I'm getting better at this oddly enough you wouldn't think that I'd be getting better at this
Knowing who I am and how good I am at games and such?
This is a mistake mistake mistake mistake, Oh, Oh my god, oh my god
I fffuuu-* turns into mouth farts*
Was fine and that I wasn't fine that was entirely my fault all right, let's try this for a dose time oh
Nope, hole
hell, yeah
Come on. That wasn't a hole. That's a hole. I know that hole that's definitely a hole
Oh, yeah, awesome hole god great hole
Yeah, just likes to dive um when it runs out of steam at random moments
Oh, yeah, there's gonna be a good hole right here. It's not a good hole
I see it's a bad hole bad hole bad. Hole Oh
Give me my points you bitch. Oh, I risk my neck for that
I mean I've killed my neck a thousand times before this, but I risk my neck at that. I hope there's something
Oh
Down okay sweet moon. Oh give me my points you bitch you bitcchhh
Give me my points I've done so Gucci I've done so gucc-. Oh Gucci gong or give me that PORTAL
Portal oh yeah, baby, okay, all right. I like you. I like it you you look like a good one with a nice
Backside Wow all right, okay. I like the way you hole I got an expert achievement that means I'm good at this right
See a hole and a hole oh come on maybe that that hole ooh, Eee
Did so good, and then I did not do so good oh
I didn't do shit there. Oh
hole me bro. hole me bro hold me bro. don't hole bro Wow I can't get this hole
Why can't I get this hole oh?
Yeah welp I'm dead all right hole time oh
Yeah, there we go oh
That was a good hole, but it didn't give me the whole bonus. There's a hole. Oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah
Oh
Yeah, oh, that's the spicy meatball. Oh, I see a spicy meatball
Oh, yeah, oh, these are some of the spiciest meatballs. I've ever seen Oh
Spicy mmm. Oh I see a spicy part-all. Oh, oh yeah. Oh yeah, that's a spice and at the bow
Let's see what we got here. Oh
This feels good
oh this feels real good. Oh another portal all right. Why not?
Mom mom please Oh seen this before haven't I miss MIStake Oh?
Mistake nailed it nailed it and nailed it
Not nailing it. Oh
Oh my god, it's can't believe I'm still alive
We're gonna go for it, Oh oh I made it oh I made it I'm so good. I'm so good at games
All right
I'm doing real good. I can't believe how good. I'm doing. Oh, this is so fun. Though like honestly this game is
To the wall this game is super fun, but also unbelievably terrifying oh my god, this is a mistake oh
God damn it. I wasn't even right rank
24,000 really good god. How bad was I oh yeah? This was a dead end oops I
Didn't I
Forgot those a mountain after the whole slot it. Yes nail it nail it nail it nail it nail it nailed it. Oh
Sick nasty maneuver sick nasty
Sick nasty maneuver, what sick nasty crash sick sick nasty disgusting crash like literally I'm about to vomit
I'm gonna get you. I'm gonna get you. No. I don't care. How many times my neck breaks. I'm gonna get you oh
Shit, oh, shit. Oh. Oh oh spice MEATBALLL
Why did I fall there? Oh cuz it didn't have enough air? Shut up.
owww
nope
Okay
Ha ha triple score baby triple scored triple score triple score triple score
it's all about keeping the triples going those sweet triple-ownesss
triple baby, Oh God mama quadruple mama
Quadruple quadruple, they're a cheater cheater. What are you talking about cheater I didn't cheat nothing?
Unless you're calling about cheating death ow.
Shit, I went there. I went there to death I went to death
This game is just a this game is incredibly addicting because I just keep wanting to jump down this mountain
It's super fun. Like I'm not lying if this game is super fun. Oh, man
*Introducing the Marki-monkye*
This game is stupid fun
Don't do that
No, no, I'll give you speed. I'll give you fuel. I'll give you fire. I'll give you that what you deserve oh
I didn't cash out my winnings
Gettin greedy. Yeah, okay, all right shut up achievement douchenozzle
don't need your input on this one
Ooooooooooooo-weeee
Man I was like coming out the Deathstar there, I've just been playing silently for a while as it
Goes like this is a super super fun like
I just want to get a decent high score that doesn't quit me in the tens of thousands of people playing
but oh well alas what can I do but be suck all day and
Suck all night
Whoa NW HIGH SCORE. New high score!  FInally after so much friggin work
After being such an idiot for so long I did I did it whoa I know less yeah
Okay alright, that's enough for now I've been playing this way too long. This is super fun
The game is not called crash the game is called Super Flight
It's available on Steam I believe and it's so much fun
So thank you everybody so much for watching check this out in the description
Let me know what you think in the comments and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye!